when Caitlin Clark did the you can't see
me gesture it was against Louisville
yeah and it looked like it was directed
towards you walk me through it from your
Vantage Point right after the game I
texted her and I was like the media is
dumb I'm sorry they just make stuff up
and then they just put it all over the
Internet and everyone thinks it's true
we were laughing about it because she
did it to her strength coach she didn't
do it to anyone on our team especially
me I didn't even see it in the game I
was probably you know dribbling the ball
at the court after she just hit a three
in our face it's just funny how like
camera angles and and perceptions are
skewed I love she said media is wrong
you guys are dumb it was hilarious we
laughed about it after so my perception
like I don't even have one because I
didn't even know what happened until I
saw it over Instagram later